last time I looked at Bruce Lee's
training in depth I examined some of the
more unusual and experimental methods
are used those included things like
speed training for instance and
overcoming isometrics but what of his
actual everyday routine we all know that
Bruce Lee believed in added in
weightlifting and cardio to his usual
martial arts practice so what did that
actually looked like was he ahead of his
time in this regard - and what can we
learn from his programs with all these
things of course we need to be careful
about the sources we rely on but
fortunately there are some fairly
verifiable reports of Bruce's training
which paints a fairly consistent picture
starting in 1965 then we have a very
early gym card that Bruce Lee filled out
detailing one of his earlier routines
this was filled out at the hack young
gymnasium in Hong Kong which he
reportedly attended three times a week
the routine was as follows squats three
times 10 at 95 pounds French press 4
times 6 at 64 pounds incline curls 4
times 6 at 35 pounds French press again
at 4 times 6 64 pounds con curls 3 times
10 at 70 to 80 pounds two-handed curls 3
times 8 at 70 to 80 pounds tricep
stretch at 3 times 8 dumbbell curl 4
times failure at 18 pounds or 4 times
infinity as he called it reverse curl 4
times 6 at 64 pounds wrist curl 4 times
failure at 6 and 4 pounds and more wrist
curls 4 times failure at 10 pounds a
slightly different version and printed
right next to this one included press
ups presumably that was just a variety
maybe this was two sessions at the gym
by the way the French press is a little
like a tricep extension sitting on a
bench whilst the Kong curl is probably
shorthand for a concentration curl it
probably is safe to assume that this
wasn't the sum total of Bruce Lee's
training more likely this would have
been part of a bro split which makes
sense given the era it would have made
up his arms day with a bit of squatting
because why the hell not I guess this is
a strange routine by all accounts it
looks as though he was curling almost as
much see he was squatting that's
probably because that was just a warm-up
he randomly performs a few exercises
twice and presumably he was training
intuitively at the time rather than
following a set routine what's also
interesting about this is that Bruce
Lee's training dedicated so much time to
his forearms and grip which does make a
lot of sense given that he was a martial
artist
looking at his forearms it's easy to see
that it did the job I've heard reports
saying that Bruce Lee's forearms were
like concrete
check out my recent video on four on
training and grip strength training for
more on how to do something similar the
tricep stretch is also very interesting
was this an example of weighted
stretching
according to Muscle & Fitness in the
book the art of expressing the human
body both of which referred to Bruce
Lee's own training notes this regime
quickly evolved into following far
simpler program so in this one he was
doing clean and press two times eight to
twelve barbell curls two times eight to
twelve behind-the-neck presses two times
eight to twelve upright rows two times
eight to twelve barbell squats ten times
twelve to twenty barbell rows two times
eight to twelve bench press two times
eight to 12 and barbell pull over two
times eight to twelve that means you
know obviously eight being a minimum
twelve being the maximum over the next
ten years Bruce Lee refine programs
further to result in the following more
scaled back approach this was clean and
press two times eight squat two times
twelve barbell pullover two times eight
benchpress two times six good mornings
two times 8 and barbell curls two times
eight he reportedly used this training
program three times a week and it was
what helped him achieve the physiques
exhibited in the big boss and the way of
the Dragon SATs in 1971 and 1972
respectively I actually tried this
routine for a couple of weeks because
what I don't think that requires an
explanation it's fairly taxing and
definitely good for mobility
I felt pretty beat up even though I was
doing it with a very light barbell at
first I will say though that I
personally would add in some kind of
triceps training especially if you're
using the first routine there's an
isolated biceps move so why not triceps
there's also an awful lot of laps in
there so it kind of makes sense to me
to swap out the pullovers for skull
crushers and personally I'd leave out
the good mornings to and maybe stick
some deadlifts in there instead but what
can we take from this well the first
thing that's interesting to note is that
is training involved into a full body
routine consisting of many more compound
movements with the exception of curls
this meant that each muscle group was
being hit three times a week which could
have potentially increases protein
synthesis there was only very moderate
intensity it's also noticeable for its
simplicity and it could actually easily
pass for quite a modern training program
bruseles stuck to predominantly two sets
of eight reps from most of these
exercises and that's something that I've
seen reported in a few places this is
enough to trigger hypertrophy but it
sits at the lower end of that spectrum
presumably that allows them to use
moderately heavy weights however this
might come as a bit of surprise for
those that may be assumed to loosely
with a more for power oriented training
programs and lower rep ranges
interestingly he believed that legs
required more repetitions than upper
body and arms that's not something you
hear a lot these days
though there are more slow twitch muscle
fibers in the legs it's something that
people quote often for the carbs so
certainly it's an interesting concept
many noted the apparent sudden
improvement in Bruce Lee's physique
going into Enter the Dragon not that he
was a slouch before and apparently this
evolution was at least partly due to his
investment in the Marcie circuit trainer
in 1972 this is basically the cable
machine that we see in gyms today and it
allowed Bruce Lee to perform everything
from the bench press to the curls to the
tricep extensions all from a single
station this coincided with Bruce's
discovery of PHA training or peripheral
heart action according to the art of
expressing the human body Bruce
discovered this training method by
reading the Ironman magazine which
reportedly was one of his favorites at
the time the idea behind PHA is to keep
the blood circulating around the body
rather than allowing it to pull in a
single muscle group or group of muscles
in other words this style of training
advocates the use of full-body circuits
over isolating single muscles or even
performing steps and reps of a single
exercise it's very similar to today's
metabolic conditioning workouts Brees
had several programs design grammars
philosophy but is most well known with
the cross-training proof team using the
Marcie circuit trainer this consisted of
pull-ups for 30 seconds seated leg press
for 30 seconds bilateral alternative hip
and knee extensions for 30 seconds
shoulder press for 30 seconds standing
calf raises using the shoulder press for
30 seconds with varying feet positions
alternating cable curls for 30 seconds
standing unilateral arm adduction for 30
seconds
bench press for 30 seconds regular
deadlift 30 seconds kneeling pulldown
behind the neck
30 seconds tricep pushdown 30 seconds
sprint for 1.5 minutes standing wrist
roller for one-minute neck flexion and
extension for
minute the aim was to use a weight heavy
enough that he would reach failure
around eight to twelve reps which was
his magic range and he would perform as
many reps as he could until failure or
until the 32nd per up as with any
circuit there was no rest in between the
movements alternate pretty much between
upper and lower body which makes sense
if the aim is to encourage as much blood
flow as possible this would then be
combined with more traditional weight
lifting regimes such as the full body
routine that we saw earlier there's
definitely some interesting inclusions
here again for instance it's interesting
that he trained his neck with the
flexion and extension which could help
him to take more blows to the head it's
interesting that he had a sprint in
there randomly before the end and once
again we now see that he's training his
forearms specifically the general idea
was something like this there was to
unify the resistance training with the
cardio training and this is a great
example of resistance cardio which I
really think is a great way to burn
calories whilst also toning up this is
the part that I'm the most dubious about
though hi by the way it seems like quite
a strange circuit to me it seems odd to
me that you'd use the Marci cross
trainer to do a circuit normally this
would lend itself better to say
bodyweight training or dumbbells etc a
bit of skipping also seems odd to me
that he does a sprint so he's like
sprinted away from his resistance
machine and then sprinted back to it in
order to finish off with some wrist
curls so I don't know I'm not saying
it's not accurate I'm just saying that
again we need to take these things the
little pinch of salt I think the author
of that book maybe had a tendency to
take some of the notes and then make his
own assumptions based on that so yes
likely he did some kind of circuit some
kind of resistance cardio whether or not
this is a perfectly accurate
representation of that I'm not so sure
on top of these strength training
protocols Bruce Lee's training also
incorporated large amounts of cardio
work specifically Bruce Lee ran three
days a week for a lot of his career
typically traveling four miles using a
fartlek approach stop sniggering fartlek
means that he would alternate his pace
just like a modern high-intensity
interval training routine he also
skipped a lot some reports having
skipping the other three days that he
didn't run meaning that he would have
been doing cardio six days a week on top
of his resistance training others
suggest that he only did three days of
cardio in most likelihood he did both
routines at different points in
training it has also been widely
reported that Bruce trained his abs in
core every single day according to
breaking muscle a sight I really like
bruce lee performs five time steps of
side bends five sets of leg raises and
five sets of sit-ups each to failure and
according to several sources he would
have done this every single day then of
course as bruce lee's martial arts
training apparently Bruce would split
his training days to focus on lower body
strikes and upper body strikes so he had
a kind of bro split for martial arts
training he believed strongly in
repetitious practise of kicks and blows
not only so that he could enhance his
technique but also so that would come a
second nature when he needed them in a
fight he always said you should practice
one kick a thousand times instead of a
thousand kicks once he also did a lot of
shallow boxing and had this to say on
the matter
shadow boxing is a good agility exercise
as well as a method for building up
speed keep your mind on the job imagine
that your worst enemy if you happen to
have one is there in front of you and go
out to give him all you've got use your
imagination to the upmost try to
anticipate the moves that your phantom
rival will endeavored to put across and
work yourself up into a real fighting
frame of mind so you can see here that
Bruce Lee really believed in
visualization training which is he know
if you watch this channel is something
that I also advocate so this is a huge
amount of training he's now doing not
only three to six days of cardio he's
also doing three days at least of weight
training may be doing a circuit on top
of that and he's trading his martial
arts most days and doing his abs every
single day that's a really heavy-duty
program and it's probably more than most
of us are going to be able to fit in
around our daily commitments remember
that Bruce Lee was a professional
martial artist and this was his job and
that always makes it much easier to
stick to an intense training program
finally keep in mind that on top of all
this Bruce Lee was constantly
experimenting like I said I covered his
use of overcoming isometrics and speed
training before none of that you'll
notice was included here he tried out
various different pieces of training
equipment even having some custom built
for him he was apparently hold dumbbells
and perform punches and Linda reports
that Bruce Lee would sit in front of a
television doing wrist curls
even when he was relaxing the point is
that whilst Bruce Lee had a fairly
conventional full body routine it was
likely his sheer dedication
inventiveness
and commitment that led to his ripped
and powerful for
Zeke as well as his incredible physical
performance Bruce Lee's training was far
more than the sum of its parts
but if you're interested in a starting
point to get physique a little bit like
Bruce Lee's then taking on one of those
full-body routines and adding in some
cardio with martial arts practice of
course would be a fairly good place to
start so thanks a ton for watching guys
hope fans feeling useful and interesting
if you did then please leave a like
please comment and subscribe all those
things help me out massively in future
I'll be returning to Bruce Lee again I
want to analyze exactly how strong he
really was in real life there's a lot of
myth and a lot of hearsay so I want to
see what is actually proven and what we
can garner about his actual real-world
performance rather than what's just
legend who begin to exceed your limits
what limit I'll also be covering many
more topics in the future of course on
bodybuilding fitness strength training
productivity flow States psychology
nootropics brain training martial arts
technology all that usual good stuff so
if that sounds good then thanks a ton
for watching and I'll see you next time
bye for now